if you've been waiting for an affordable
graphics card that can give you a very
good gaming experience then you've no
doubt heard all the rumors about the AMD
rx480 that have everyone has been
waiting on hearing about for a long time
and you guys have been told over and
over June 29th June 29th you can hear
about it June 29th that you all kept
asking how does it perform well guys
I've got the 8 gig model right here I
put it through a Gambit of tests and
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about this card where it
belongs how I feel about it and whether
or not you should even consider
it whether you're looking for a pump
reservoir custom GPU block or a complete
Loop in a box Alpha Cool's wide range of
products can make your next water
cooling Adventure an easy one click the
link in the description for more
details now quick disclaimer before we
get into the benchmarks I know we
promised we'd get right into it but I
want you guys to understand what it is
you're seeing here I use the same test I
always do with all of my graphics cards
and I left ashes of the singularity out
not because I don't trust it the Dev
have actually made changes on that so
the textures look the same regardless of
the GPU load it's the fact that I'm
still having problems with the damn
Benchmark for some reason I'm getting
very erratic results not with this card
but with some of the other cards that I
was testing with it so I'll come back to
it but the other thing too is I compared
it to the sapphire 380x Nitro Edition
which is a custom PCB 380x Nitro which
was the previous last gen 300 80 series
card from AMD and I compared it to the
970 SSC which yes is a more expensive
card by more than $100 at the time of
launch I don't know what current pricing
is this exact moment but at the time of
launch it was more than $100 more than
this card so why did I do that well when
AMD was here I they actually came to my
office here spent time with me and we
went over the card so I can understand
more about this card and why it exists
and where it's designed to compete and I
flat out asked the question who is this
card aiming at who is this card trying
to take down when it comes to
Performance they said for pricing it's
aimed more at where the 960 launched but
for performance it's got the 970
straight in its crosshairs so did it
actually compete with the 970 at a much
lesser price well let's look at the
benchmarks and find out transition
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
now obviously when you look at those
benchmarks you you can see that in most
of the tests the 970 Edge did this guy
out by just a little bit but I want to
point something out that 970 is an EVGA
SSC super super clocked so you've got
the 970 reference and then you've got
the super clock and then you've got the
super super clock which actually has
extra power phases and stuff in it so it
is not a standard 970 it's actually a
custom PCB with more power and more
frequency in it whereas this is just a
reference card now why didn't I use just
a standard 970 in the test easy I don't
have one so I couldn't actually go back
and retest it but yeah I I I digress
that's exactly how the 970 SSC performed
when it launched versus how this is
performing on the latest Crimson drivers
which obviously we had Early Access to I
did ask if the drivers were going to
change between when I did my test and
now and when you guys can get them and
they said no so that's um that's it
that's that's the way you guys should be
getting it hopefully as long as nothing
goes wrong but as you could see in some
Test 2 with 1440p and even 4K although
this is not a 4K card neither is the 970
neither is the 380x I just want to see
how they scaled under like 100% massive
load where the graphics card is just
buckling under the weight of all of
those pixels and it held its own very
very well edging out the 970 in quite a
few tests and as you guys could see at
1080 it was like right there with the
970 trailing behind it just a little bit
in some tests but then just like you
know completely pimp slapping in another
test which is very impressive
considering the card has 8 GB it's a
1266 MHz core which is the highest core
clock we've seen yet from uh anything to
come out of amd's Camp especially at
this price point and that it's running
8,000 MHz effective memory so the 4 GB
version is exactly the same it's just
cut down to 4 GB 256bit memory bus all
of that now it also has something that I
thought was really neat because I opened
up MSI After Burner and I wasn't
expecting this um I was actually
directed to go into the uh control
Center for crimson and then go into the
global settings inside of where all the
games are and then you actually have
overclock control within the driver so
it's a driver level overclocking
available onto this card where you don't
have to rely on thirdparty software to
integrate for it like MSI afterburner or
any of the other software I guess that
the other companies launch you can
actually do driver level overclocking
with this which was very uh nice to see
you can control things like fan curve
you can even control the P States now P
states are a lot like GPU boost where
it's going to under certain load
conditions it's going to go to a certain
frequency and certain voltage control so
you guys are sometimes people ask me I
don't understand why it'll be in the
middle of a test and then suddenly it'll
drop down like a step of megahertz and
then it will step up and then we'll step
down why is it doing that well guys
that's all piece dates and this is uh
something that is actually being you're
giving access to Now with uh AMD where
you can actually control those P States
and actually control the voltage for
each one of those individually which is
giving you a much better overclocking
experience in my opinion now this does
all of this guys at 150 W total TDP
single six pin connector as well as 75
Watts coming through the PCI Lane for
150 wat TDP it is not a a power draw
whatsoever now the card obviously got
hot but that's a blower style cooler
which you should expect uh from any
blower style cooler with a very um
conservative fan curve the way it ships
out of the box it would rather it be
very quiet and get hot than being noisy
and not as hot so I turned up the the
power Cur or the fan curve to see what
would happen temperatures dropped down
below ADC obviously the decb of it went
very high another thing I tested for
with this card was coil wine and I'm
pleased to announce that it is very low
on coil wine it was not intrusive it was
not like the fury where the fury was
just coil whing like crazy and
screeching like a banshee no this was
not noisy at all in an open air test
bench when it comes to coil wine um one
thing I want to point out though is they
did remove the DV ID connector from the
back of the card so if you are using a
monitor and you're using a DVI cable
you're going to have to either switch
over to display port or get yourself a
display port to DVI adapter or something
like that where you can then plug it
into your card they did say that the
board partners are going to have access
to solder points that are on the PCB so
they can add that back so that's
something you're going to have to look
for when it comes to the custom board
partner cards uh to see exactly what
they're going to be throwing in now look
at the size of that PCB right it looks
like a pretty big card not well not
pretty big it's a pretty decently the
average size card but you can see here
the PCB is actually very short and it's
very dense that allowed them to go with
a bigger heat sink on here have the
blower hang off the back and push air
across the entire length of the card but
again it's going to be up to the board
Partners on what type of cooling
solutions they're going to come up with
inevitably you know they're going to
come up with multifan solutions that
blow down on the card um so it's going
to be interesting to see if it stays as
short as this or if they're going to be
doing custom PCB options to make it
longer so they can fit all those fans on
there or if they're just going to
overhang the heat seek off the back of
the card and do fans across it anyway
which we've seen them do in the past now
one thing that AMD also advertises with
this card is that it is VR capable now
there's a lot of Technology going on in
graphics cards when it comes to VR and
I'll admit that I'm not prepared to talk
about that today that is going to be
something that needs to happen on
another video and now that I have
purchased my H HTC Vive I can actually
do some VR testing because graphics
cards go under intense load when it
comes to V
and the level of consistency they have
to draw the frames so if this was having
any trouble it would be very very
noticeable and we will check that out
just unfortunately not today but I think
right now if you're looking for a new
graphics card and you've only got about
$200 to $240 to spend uh the fact that
you can for 239 bucks get an 8 GB card 8
GHz effective memory speed 1,266 MHz and
guess what I was able to actually
overclock this to
1,360 that's the highest core clock I've
gotten on any AMD card I have ever
touched in the history of me doing this
channel yeah this little guy just seems
to keep surprising us and that's the
thing everybody hyped this card hyped
hyped hyped hyped hyped hype hype and I
hate hype train because often hype
trains derail but that didn't happen
here this card continued to impress me
the more I played around with it Doom 3
1440p High settings 60 FPS no problem
whatsoever I can't wait to see what the
custom cards are going to hold from the
board partners and you know I'm going to
review those so keep your eyes peeled
for that anyway guys it went on sale
today June 29th rx480 you guys tell me
what you think did it did it hold up to
the hype you know there's a ton of VI
videos out right now about this tons of
reviews so go and check those out not
just don't just take my word for it
please please do yourself a favor watch
all the reviews or at least two or three
of them to kind of get a better sampling
of what's Happening we all have a little
bit different test methodology we all
use a little bit different settings and
I think it's important for you to kind
of try try and develop a big picture
based on what multiple people were
saying and not just Jay said blah blah
blah blah but there you go rx480 I'm
nicknaming this thing the Little Beast
because it really is well actually it's
not the first thing I've named the
little beast but I digress so with all
that said this card sits pretty much all
alone in the sub $300 range when it
comes to to graphics cards when I say
sub 300 we mean deep 199 right for 4 gig
239 for 8 gig that's a pretty big deal
and because it's sitting all alone right
there in that price point that is where
most people shop it's right around there
there's some statistic out there it's
like 85% of people shop for graphics
cards that are $250 or less right now
it's all by itself so the ball is in
nvidia's court to see how they're going
to respond because we all know that
competition in the space is great for
consumers so we need some competition
out there and right now AMD clearly wins
this price point for now anyway guys
thanks for watching watching tell me
what you thought let me know if this
card lived up to the hype or did it
disappoint sound off in the comments hit
me up on Twitter or come to Facebook and
if you don't want to do any of those
things well then hopefully I'll see you
in the next video if you're new here hit
the Subscribe button it's um guaranteed
way to know when I put up a video so
that you can just like make fun of me
that's more that's fun that's a fun
Pastime just plenty of ammo waiting for
you guys just to shoot all right I don't
know what else I'm going to say so I
guess it's time to go all right guys
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one